[Music]
hello everybody my name is Vitaly namer
I am the Grand Master resident here the
same to his chess club and today we are
going to discuss how to play like a pro
I'm gonna go I'm gonna show you a few
miniatures which are quick games which
were played pretty famous games very
tactical games but before that I would
like to show you one of our members club
members a game and he requested them to
analyze it so let's see what happened
let's see what happened and we have
Peter playing white and Suresh playing
black so let's see so II for C 5 so we
have the Sicilian defense Knight f3 d6
ok so so far so good
d4 pawn takes 24 Knight X and d4 Knight
to f6 Knight to c3 and a6 yeah so
basically this is all very known this is
what we call the neither of opening in
the variation in the Sicilian opening
very popular among grandmasters war
champions one of the most complicated
game variations that we ever have in the
chest here wife pretty much tried
everything like a tree root b1 Bishop d3
Bishop g5 after year for G 2 h 2 ug 1
Bishop e2 Bishop d3 Bishop c4 Queen e2
Queen f3 and so on and so on
I mean the amount of moves here and that
that's why tried is just astonishing ok
right so oh you played g6 ok so sorry
about that so Jesus was played ok so
going form the night of going into the
dragon alright
the dragon is making a comeback by the
way I have played a few times by acharya
nakamura and i remember myself when i
was a kid i I think everybody
learns yeah everybody knows the dragon
is such such a cool name but there are
cool names if you see my my youtube
video about openings which are called by
animal names I have just made part one
but it's gonna be it well to some of
those the Hedgehog
we had the kangaroo defense we had the
hippo and I think nothing sounds else
cause dragon though so I invented my own
opening which I call the Hydra system
and the hydras I can drag over two heads
so there's a mythological creature
okay so g6 Bishop to e2 yeah so actually
here the main line for wife is to play
Bishop to e3 usually White is supposed
to go for the Yugoslav attack which is
famous by white casting alongside and
starting to push his pawns on the on
this side so Bishop to it
so instead of white played Bishop to e2
Bishop to g7 now Bishop to e3 Castle
Queen d2 okay interesting so it looks it
looks to me like there was some kind of
a transposition of moves but basically
white is making us wonder if we go how
are we going to castle long are we going
to cast a short a what to do so okay so
every dragon player knows probably the
next move so night usually comes to c6
but I assume if we go to c6
I wonder if Wyatt can play this move
Bishop h6 which he can't write a fighter
tries to immediately exchange the
bishops it's just going to lose this
Knight just take this knife so I will
suggest to black to play here 96 this
would be the one of the most common
common ways to play this another way to
play this is because why did not play
this move f3 we might be able to play in
94 and this move Knight g4 will get us
this Bishop on the tree and this Bishop
on d3 is very
valuable for white because of two things
first of all this bishop defense is 94
and also it is used to exchange our
dragon head here on g7 so this Knight to
g4 could be possible but if I will be on
the safe side I open in 96
in the game black played Knight B to d7
and I think this is the first step into
just into a very passive passive
structure usually I recommend to my
students not to place those nights like
this I call them the ghost nights
they're just kind of looking at each
other like that twins pretty much so
yeah so basically that was tricking each
other so this is why I like to you know
in May most of the openings we like to
put the night seal on c6 and Knight f6
like what the full night's opening and
for example the specialty curve many
many openings openings would like to put
them here and here so they control
different squares so at night to be
seven bt7 was not the best one long
castle was played by by white and now
record a six again now we start kind of
the the Yugoslav attack white starts to
push his pawns I think though that a six
is usually a very it's a bit slow in
those kind of positions just to
illustrate the main the main the main
line of the of the Dragon is Bishop to
e3 Bishop to g7 f3 Castle 2296 Bishop c4
Bishop d7 long casts on our roots rook
c8 so comparing this position to what
black got in the game to this position
what are the what are the castle it is
black to move in this position
I already developed my bishop and my
rook and my night as well and usually
the plan is to play 95 and the 94 so a6
is just too slow h4 is the regular idea
for for white to page 5 but did try to
play a try himself but usually
doesn't play so well because the h5 is
gonna act as a hook and we know that now
it's gonna get attacked white played f3
I think Oh F for its here it says f2 so
I know that you played without the F to
pawn
it's probably FT because ft is going to
support you for night d-35 ok came to be
one Bishop d7 Knight d2 BT yeah I don't
see a reason why white would do this
usually white would just sacrifice do
something like g4 even sacrifice a pawn
just open all the files yeah yeah black
y can probably play even even here yeah
g4 and the idea is that if if it takes
well you can take the pawn and then h5
take maybe I can play chess or maybe now
after it looks super dangerous also
knife can come to a five yeah so it's
just a race usually in the dragon
disarray so it's gonna make you first if
you don't want to play G fold and you
shouldn't cast alongside you should
Castle short side so here Knight to b3
so it looks like but that black is
getting getting gaining some momentum
but now Queen to c7 was played Queen c7
gets into this this Knight to d5 a move
which was played in the game I would
suggest again we can just start playing
b5 probably all I can I I just need to
the finish of my development I know that
the rook will need to be on open files
so something active rook c8 so Queen c7
was played at night C to d5 take Queen
takes Bishop e6 oh that's good this
black is activating his Bishop Queen d2
rook FC 8 okay that's good that's nice
Knight B to D for okay then I decided to
back a Bishop c4 okay that's that's good
Luke c1 b5 all right so it looks like
black is doing pretty pretty good job
coming back
f4 trying to kick out the night while
black - Connie - in the intermediate
move F takes e5 oh and here's well back
to 25 yeah yeah so so instead so if we
take you the bishop that's the problem
that we just you just lose a piece 90 c2
so here we need to take with a pawn and
although even if even if we take the
pawn black white still can take with the
night and piece a piece piece down so a
little too painful especially for the
night comes you to to defy right so a
suggestion for my students is always if
somebody is attacking you I know that we
learn we always do this this cool phrase
you know the best defense is offense
it's actually not just just go you know
just defend yourself first instead of
instead of doing some some other action
because you know in in all the action
movies that's it's a stunt right you
know it's all about computerized so you
just just just move backwards just move
the knight so I'm up
g47 and you you you live to fight
another day at night Knight to c6 would
be good any any kind of move then if it
takes to take the Queen and actually I
might do the would of prefer the black
here I'm I'm not so sure
again if Y would never play this move g4
maybe psychologically what doesn't want
to give up at this pawn I would
definitely prefer to be black because my
knight is going to come here harass
those those pawns well yeah it's a it's
an interesting pawn structure right like
we saw we just discuss the the pawn in
the pot let's show that this is the
dragon the dragon structure and one of
my one of my lessons for the
kids class was about the dragon and I
was asking a why is it called the
dreaded dragon so anybody anybody knows
why is it's called the dragon now what I
know well the kids know so you guys
can't answer let it let the adults try
to figure this out why is it called the
dragon this this this opening yeah
that's that's the mole that's the most
common response and they always say that
okay this is the head of the dragon this
is the fire and this is the tail this is
when I was young this is what I learned
this is kind of the spikes but there is
actually an original reason for that
anybody knows what's the other reason
yes very good yes so it's actually was
named after the consolation and you know
we have this after this the stars we
have different chains of stars
okay different constellations and this
this constellation is pretty similar to
the Draco consultation and this is why
it was called the dragon yeah so every
day you learn something new there is oh
there is also a Chinese dragon yeah this
is this is a involving the dog to be
eight that's that's something different
though okay so so a good game I would
say that definitely black did get some
some some momentum but after losing a
piece yeah for black okay great question
is so the question is do we need to play
this move h5 here and sometimes yes
sometimes no usually what black does not
want to play h5 because it's gonna act
as a hook for example if white plays
here f3 and if a g4 immediately you
already have to worry about here so
usually what happens is that let's say
you play you know b5 I have to play
f 3 and then I played 95 then I played
g4 and only now I play h5 only now I get
to my pawns
so sometimes usually when we have the
the pawns from the King you don't want
to move them away usually but in some
special cases h5 is necessary for
example here you know you played against
somebody who was afraid to play g4 so if
you can feel it if you can sense a
college psychologically @ h5 is really
going to stop his attack then you might
play it so so good job ok guys we're
going to go into our lesson into a main
lecture today and again we are going to
see a few games that were 120 moves this
is what we call the miniatures very very
fast games ok so the the first game is
is pretty pretty famous it was only
finished in four moves just four moves
and this is not the this is not the
skulls mate this is not a to move mate
this was actually you know this was
actually almost a checkmate somebody
resigned after the move number four but
he does it deserved to resign so so
that's let's see what happened this this
is played between be bald and lasered in
1924 so white solid wood this move d4
and by the way what's amazing is that
black won this game
so usually white is the one is who is
winning the those miniatures because he
starts the game but then this one black
one won the game okay so d4 Knight f6 so
far so good how can you lose this now
wife makes this interesting move date
white has so many moves here you can
play Bishop g5 Tom Pope's key why it can
also play try to play this most c4 so
this is the the mainline Knight f3 g3 so
many moves Knight c3 well in this case
why play this move Knight to d2
probably why it was figuring okay I want
to somehow get my opponent of his
preparation do something of the book and
see see what happens obviously the idea
here of 92 is just simply too pushy fall
on the next moment now the main move for
black would be what what wants to
suggest a move for black how do we
prevent efore d5 right so d5 would be
the main move and I think that black has
no no problems we always use this move
another another option for us is
actually to attack this point e4 and
there are two ways the first one is c5
more of a Ben Oni style because if if we
play c5 then you can play e4 because he
is losing the pawn here on d4 but black
had a tricky population he played not c5
what he played d5 now by the way there
is there is a specific opening when
white starts with default a5 this is go
to England but this is not the same okay
well white white was thinking about this
position and he said okay well I guess I
have to take the pawn otherwise well
what else can I do
so he to the pawn and black said okay
well I'm you know my night is getting
attacked so I have to move it with the
Knights humble and I also want to get my
knight back so the knight simply went to
g4 so far so good
well now a white so this night and he
played h3 okay just just just kicking
the knight out of there and this is move
number four and this this move h3 was a
total disaster just total disaster
because black did not take the pawn here
only five buddy plays
nice - III damn that's a that's pretty
painful and the idea is that now why
this losing is quick Queen here it's
more almost like a smothered made to the
Queen and if the night if white is
taking this night then we have this nice
checkmate now it's almost looks like a
checkmate in two moves almost similar
idea and g3 Quinte g3 and it's gonna be
a checkmate so yes this was pretty
painful so obviously the main mistake
was this move h3 and that lots of
options that white can play here but for
example Y can play something like just
Knight 2 F 2 F 3 which would defend
against this threat and you know black
will still win the pawn back by playing
96 but at least you're not getting
checkmated so yeah so all we always
think about about your move and try not
to make such moves like HD in the
beginning of the of the game now not so
healthy that's a healthy okay so this
was game number one just in four moves
let's go to our next our next game
between morphe and understand in 1858 so
that makes it that's if my math is
correct 170 60 thank you
one 160 years ago so it's pretty old
game I'm by the way I'm always amazed by
the history and how even those games
were saved
okay so let's so let's see so this game
is going to be in 17 moves this is a
moves number one and this was the eighth
game of the match which was worn between
Murphy and Anderson if I remember
correctly
back then Devil's the one of the
strongest players if you can call this
call them world champions back then and
what happened is that Andrew something
that black was too aggressive and that's
why he got defeated usually we know that
when we are playing black you want to
always to equalize first and only then
go on to the offense so let's see what
happens so II for c5 again we see the
Sicilian defense here and again lots of
options for white to play here the main
move is a knight of three obviously
there is Knight c3 which is the closest
iliyan but more people further dis more
water if they'd if they'd kind of not
exactly gambit but he played d4 and
black takes on default but still needs
to take on d4 and now Knight Knight to
f3 now the idea is that there's there's
black black can protect the pawn for
example with E 5 if you wants to because
if Knight takes e5 then black plays
Queen to a5 it's a nice little trap but
after E 5 a white can play for example C
3 giving away a pawn I'm sacrificing a
pawn but to get this nice pawn structure
and it is nice outputs on d5 it's quite
debatable if it's enough compensation
but this is one of the one of the ways
to to play this so black decided not to
play e5 but just to play the regular
move ninety-six knight Knight takes on
on d4 now a six again many options you
have to play with black d6 96 g6 can be
transposed into the what we call the
accelerated dragon for example here this
move the accelerate dragon is being
played without the move d6 so that's
something for Dragon players to consider
you know if you want to be a dragon that
you want to be a facile dragon anyway in
the game black played this move is six
and so the user move for for white is to
play just Knight c3 here but why I
decided that the e6 are the e6 move
creates some weaknesses and the weakness
here is here on d6 and so why I decided
to play Knight to b5 we see it in the
openings like this especially Cove and
the kalashnikov of many times well black
is pushing the opponent hill on a six or
a five then immediately he gets this
kind of a pothole on d6 and this is what
our pieces want to go so II six was
played Knight to Knight to d5 black
really doesn't doesn't need to doesn't
need to allow the knighthood go to jump
to d6 so he plays d6 himself this this
kinds of kind of pawn structure by the
way we call the Hedgehog this is another
enemy looks like do we have lots of
animals here and this is because those
pawns kind of look like a spikes so d6
okay why to move out to play here with
white so so far we wasted a lot lots of
time with this knight Knight f3 94 95
and in our next move the problem is that
black is just simply going to play a six
and he's going to kick out neither way
so why did we do it all of this so
really here white needs to make a
provoking move so why to move
Bishop g5 okay this is g5 I held Bishop
f4 okay anybody else
c4 maybe yeah
yeah so basically those two moves our
other main moves our candidate moves
Bishop g5 Bishop f4 and c4 c4 goes into
some kind of a Marazzi bind structure
this is when what we call in the city
and why we put the pawn here on c4 very
interesting move trying to prevent that
from any kind of play by playing d5 or
b5 so this is possible Bishop g5 I think
it might be too risky because first of
all and then I can just jump on f6 Oh
Bishop e7 but also I'm wondering if I
can take this night and this Bishop on
g5 and here here take I wonder if I'm
going to get this night over there
after b6 Bishop d7 and I'm going to get
two pieces and my queen here is very
active so interesting idea but does not
work in this case so the correct move is
Bishop to f4 and the idea here is that
we want to take this pawn on d6 it looks
like we also discussed lots of porn
structures in this game and those games
and likely to defend the spawn the only
way to defend this pawn is to play this
move e5 so this is the the provocation
what one of the one of the weaknesses of
porno visit pawns cannot move backwards
and forever we White is gonna have this
nice outputs on d5 which we usually like
to occupy by by Knights so if I was
played Bishop to e3 simply be simply
went back and now black needs to
probably transpose into the smash neck
of defense and there are lots of moves
here but one of the main ones that will
be Knight of 6 and then the again White
has a choice here I can either play c4
here or 93
and then black plays a six and so on and
so on but as we said Anderson felt
wasn't a fighting spirit that day and he
decided okay I I want to play a fight
attacking attacking the spawn on only
four okay so what to do here we we you
know we we stumbled upon this this this
opening
we're playing white baby back wants to
check made us what to do
okay 92 is an idea yeah
Queen h5n8 wife check okay Bishop c4
yeah that's that's also both looks
pretty interesting right because they
weaken the diagonal yeah so 93 which
attack by the way to see three nothing
be okay which night on beyond see three
yes by the way yeah usually when we
notate if all night was on ee2 for
example we could say night b2 c3 but in
this case we have both of the night on
the B file so the way to notate this
move would be night 5 2 C 3 or night 1
to C 3 so we recognize them by by the
the rank so yeah so lots of good moves
and why just keeps up his development
they played Knight to c3 now the idea
for black was actually to play this not
to take you on d4 but to play f4 very
aggressive play by black he wants to
control more space on the on the Kings
side and saying hey you know you have to
move your Bishop back and then I'm going
to develop my knight and my life is
beautiful
unfortunately here
well he doesn't care exactly and he you
know he black is making his own plans
what is executing his own plans so white
to move what will be the best move now
Quinn on d5 okay if I take the the
bishop positional sacrifice okay maybe
maybe maybe you're correct
ninety five and also second everybody
wants to sacrifice the bishop today
nobody likes the bishop male yes exactly
bishop takes it for is an option yeah
and if okay so all of those options we
have to consider what happens if we lose
the bishop right so bishop takes it for
I take Bishop c4 I take the bishop Queen
d5 I also take the bishop we need some
kind of a concrete variation I know that
if Queen defy for example take the
bishop Bishop c4 maybe trying to
checkmate on f7 black and probably just
defend with Knight h6 and peaceful might
be too much of a sacrifice going to G
for almost a checkmate well so this is
what almost would happen in the game so
now white plays Knight to d5 again using
that that outputs for the Knights black
decided to take away three there's
really no defense by the way on 47 for
the Knights to comment c7 so black take
two Calitri now the question is which
type needs to come to c7
will be denied or the B night
so think about this beam I told Dean I'd
be okay why be why not D
it will do D okay because it will take
something well both of both of them will
take something even if you play B or D
you need to restrict the e7 square okay
maybe
okay yes B be like a baby or D like a
daddy baby okay okay so you prefer
moving the baby because the baby will be
attacked by a okay anybody here for the
deadly night daddy okay we have some
some daddy
okay so daily versus the baby sounds
good well both of them are pretty good
we just need to kind of calculate it it
all depends how you see it first of all
the night and on on the d4 d5 supposed
to be better why is that well because
it's more placed in the center that's
that's pretty logical the question is do
we need this this this this square for
the Queen maybe to come here so for
example one of the options were one of
the members here mentioned is if I check
with the D Knight and King D 7th and
there is Queen G for checkmate actually
not not made exactly but King is 7 and
looks pretty close to the checkmate
there might not be a checkmate King F 7
then probably Queen d5 maybe here but
then the King's on while the King runs
away from the daddy and the baby so in
the game why played Knight B to C 7
that's because you know the baby the
baby checks the king that is a stichting
the king only 7 so anyway so this was
what was playing again rope Knight B to
d7 the king went to f7 well now he must
go there because now our after king
the seven queen g4 okay now it's now
it's a family affair they stick the
Queen the daddy and the baby one looking
on the King so anyway it's a king to
have seven I was played in the game and
we'd like to would like to create to
move our pieces with the tempos we can
take the rook here when they ate but
that's going to create some kind of
chances for black so why I decided to
play Queen to f3 a check that's what we
call a move of the tempo we gained we
gained some time so check Knight to f6
okay why to move again now we need to
choose do we take the the 91 of six do
we take the rook here do we take the
pawn here on it's only three maybe we
need to do something else maybe we have
to prepare for a castle still unclear I
mean and and by the way we're a piece
down we sacrificed a piece so why to
move think about what would be the best
way to continue our attack so this
position is all about time so for
example do we want to take this pawn to
e3
probably not I mean just a pawn we will
always be able to take it we don't
really care about this poetry do we want
to take this look on the 8th again no
because if we take here on the rook on
on a8 that could have the time to
reorganize these pieces play something
like context of f2 maybe you can also
play Bishop g4 attacking the Queen we
cannot lose any time and we see that the
King is exposed very much and we will
always want to bring more members of our
family into play by playing Bishop to c4
so the threat right now is night xf6
lots and lots of discovered checks so
Knight Bishop to c4 was played Bishop e6
will not help because we can just take
the bishop the King cannot escape
anywhere so black decided to
counter-attack again
Knight to d4 BAM
it's the lone knight here attacking
everything attacking the Queen after
attacking the opponent situ wants to
focus but luckily for us we have we
replaced our bishop on c4 so now we
start to get rid of his pieces Knight
takes f6 check discover attack yes
d5 Bishop takes on d5 check and now
black isn't cost crossroad what to do
what to do how can we defend we have
three options we have King g6 we have
King e7 and we also have 96 and Bishop
e6 which one of them which one of them
is the best for black right right so you
want to keep your King as as close as
possible to you to your army so King e7
was the correct move after which were
white could have played nigth check for
example then Queen f7 but unfortunately
in the game and their son always moves
forward even in this position and he
attacks even with the king came to g6
he's not scared he's not scared but
unfortunately here there is a very nice
combination Queen to h5 check we move
our queen away from the threat of being
taken so that's a very important temple
even though we lose the knight on only
three okay so what to do here with white
if you give black time by the way I'm
going to take one c7 and want agency to
with the check and it's going to be not
so easy for us to to checkmate just with
the Queen and the bishop Queen h4
interesting okay and if I play g5 Queen
f7 okay and then King g5 h for King h6
almost almost looks like a bug house
game yeah so 1998 is interesting but the
prowl 98 is Queen takes Knight Queen
takes Knight Bishop before check I'm
going to take your queen of the rock if
we exchange the Queen's over here
there's going to be the end of our
attack
I have to decide is it is it the Queen
f7 or is it something else and why is
that right so the idea we need to bring
more mobile army into the game so f
takes on e3 that's correct and that is
to Castle and to bring the rook in so
okay so black played Knight takes on c2
he tried to to check and bring in the
denied out but why just played moved
came to e2 and basically here black
resigned
so let's see why he resigned if it takes
on a1 the knight a e8 check now why is
that working now because the King went
away from this check this discover check
and if King is 7 then Queen f7 checkmate
if in this position black tries to take
this Knight and c7 preventing from 9810
rook HT f1 check King is 7 rook F 7 in
the eighth
rook takes King takes rook c1 and
although there is no checkmate that's
that's pretty hopeless yeah so so
remember this remember this it's a good
lesson and when we are playing with
black first we want to act equalized
okay at least Castle and then start
attacking your opponent let's look at
the second second game this was in 17
moves the second game will be in 18
moves so everything under 20 moves this
game was played in 1820 even earlier
than other the prior game and this was
played by Napoleon
she was right well we'll see we'll see
exactly well if you beat him then he
might you know cut your head off or
something
Napoleon vs. Burton's so let's see let's
see what happens in in this game so II
for was played g5 Knight f3 nothing
special 96 and d4
Napoleon is playing the scotch game
which is split decent decent opening
with it with white used to be played a
lot by Garry Kasparov in his prime time
the correct move here is to take this
pawn with the with the pawn we have to
take the pawn before otherwise we will
we will allow Y to gain more space but
but trans I didn't know that and he took
with the night but this was a big waste
big mistake so 90s d4 Knight takes d4 he
takes d4 now theoretically speaking the
the correct move for white is to just to
take this pawn on d4 and although we
have a queen here in the center of the
board which usually not recommended in
in openings nobody can read the italic
of the Queen for example even c5 would
be a not such a good move public queen a
4 or queen d1 and again white is gonna
get this very nice output for the knight
on d5 so Napoleon decided not to take
the pony for but to play Bishop c4 in
those ages it was very very common to
sacrifice a lot play very active I mean
just just a pawn just a point so Bishop
to c4 was played black played Bishop to
c5 defending the pawn and now c3
see three was played again the idea is
to sacrifice another pawn taking it
wants to take him on d4 if black takes
you all on city well white has two
options you can either Castle
sacrificing another pawn but creating
lots and lots of initiative for white
with the two bishops and then the Queen
is come gonna come here somewhere on d5
and blacks position is very very scary
or if white wants what can even take
that the pole with the night and this is
just a simple gambit again that we we
sacrifice a pawn but we get the
advantage and development well
black I thought that he can be sneaky
and he played this move Queen three
seven and the idea was well if the if
the pawn takes on d4 I wanna take on e4
check we want to check you attack this
pawn and that I even attack the G to
pawn well it did not work so well for
for the for the sneaky guy and well
white simply Castle here and the problem
now is obviously the Queen cannot take
on only four because of this QR again
black still have a chance to make the
correct move again probably I have to
take on c3 or play some 96 or night of
six I have to keep my development I need
to develop my pieces but instead black
played Queen to e5
what's the idea of this move 25 well
basically blacks would black was
thinking okay well if it takes the pawn
on d4 I'm going to take with my queen
and at least I can try to exchange
Queens well Napoleon was not only a
great general but also pretty good
tactician with white so how did he play
quite a move
f4 yes all forces full ahead
f4 black to consider a check that does
not scare us came to h1 simply move the
king away
pawn takes on b2 very scary what to do
take the Queen take the bishop take the
pawn take on f7 take the Queen so do we
take the Queen first or do we take the
pawn on f7 first how do we decide yes
Queen why the Queen well you're gonna
take a quit anyway do you guys all gonna
take up the Queen only five anyway right
doesn't matter if you take a left seven
first we're gonna take on a seven later
the question is about the the move order
in this position so which move order
would be better for white okay so taking
the Queen first and then taking on f7
because your defendant well we have we
need to compare right so we can either
take of the coup the Queen and then
taken of seven the King has to move what
happens if we take on the other end of
seven though then his King might take
out Bishop and then you cast then then
if the King takes on f7 they would take
if I over the tempo okay King goes back
and now if they couldn't be two now we
just a queen up okay there's just
justice this is just a more tricky way
to do it because if we take the Queen
first then it takes it takes the rook
with that kind of 71 you won't have this
option to fall into our trap and you
will move the King okay so when you have
a choice between taking a queen and
taking a pawn you're taking the pawn I
remember that okay so what a white took
on f7 check black did not fall into this
trap if they'd came to d8 okay well now
we need to take on e5 we took a queen
but fortunately another one was born
okay well how to continue here with
white
okay we can play Bishop g5 yes what else
ecigs okay
now forget it as we broke down right now
rook and the pawn broking upon down and
we have to be we have to calculate the
calculate very strictly okay Bishop
takes g8 so we so we have Bishop takes
g8 Bishop g5 e six any other solutions
this is pretty much I'll carry on it
moves right each six we need to open up
the D file taking on g8 and Bishop to g5
is one of the action moves that we have
captures of threats so which one of
those yeah so as far so if we compare
those ideas well e 6 is just below me to
slow there's nothing there's not even a
threat if it takes I just take the with
this after EC second probably play
something like Queen d4 and block this
just this file as well as try to
exchange Queens so do it
Queen c2 probably maybe quintic c5 so if
we play Bishop g5 check immediately then
Knight is gonna come for the help so
first of all we have to get rid of the
bodyguards and Napoleon knew that you
always have to get rid of the body girls
first in war you have to go for the king
right so that's how you win a war so
Bishop takes g8 and the whole idea was
is that black cannot take on g8 because
if it takes on g8 now what is the strong
move Queen to b3
and it's pretty difficult here for black
if it tries to exchange rooks for
example think they think that I can
bring Queen f7 Bishop c5 now Bishop g5
check with a checkmate for example oh
oops I'm sorry this checkmate yes Oh
Queen g8 yes
Oh Bishop e7 it is so bishop takes G g8
and black played Bishop to e7 he said
okay I have a rule Cup let's at least
prevent Bishop to g5 check but in this
case why just play the Queen to b3 put
defending the bishop on on g8 defending
the knight on b3 so right now we have a
knight versus a rock in a pond and the
threat is there should be two
and blacks black was supposed to take
here on an e5 and this releases Quinn
somehow but unfortunately played this
move a five and the idea was that if
white plays Bishop b2 maybe I can play a
four but White has a winning plan here
let's see we can find it so we move
number thirteen we have just five more
walls left Bishop g5 ok Queen takes e5
okay that's a mate but they said that we
said that you have to make me in five
moves so they're Dov's why two moves
better I mean if what if I want to make
my opponents off a little bit more yeah
very good
so this is very very force we'll just
look for some checks so check on the on
the Fate check on the e7 check check
I'm eight that's okay that's okay few if
your solution was also good what if you
would start with Bishop to g5 I'm
interested to see if this is also being
made it looks like it's gonna be a mate
as well but here we just need to
calculate lots of lots of things and I
wonder if you can play Bishop takes okay
so check here probably checkmate like
this right Bishop g5 so you're typing to
do rook F a checkmate how do I defend
against stroke of fate okay can i sack
my queen here she's not she's not doing
there anyway anyway anything I'm gonna
take the bishop
probably probably need to take and what
do we have here chaos yes it's probably
also winning for white but if you can if
you can check with your opponent in a
forcing line like okay faith check check
and mate that's that'll be the easiest
one okay guys thank you for joining me
today was a pleasure and I'll see you
next week
[Music]
you
[Music]